[Music]
it's all over it's in every town and
every city
it's in villages
they're everywhere they're all over town
every shop
every time i go to town i see at least
one of them
the problem in this country is so
monumental that it's far easier to
pretend it's not there
what is this place that you're taking me
to just talk me through it
it's where sexual activities happen
[Music]
when it's dark it's quiet there's no one
here you can't see anything up here
it's really desolate isn't it
sarah is not just haunted by the men who
sexually abused her from the age of 14
they still abuse her so how much further
a bit further i don't suppose there's
much traffic here at night
no no this is a story about authorities
failing to act and protect women who
report
sexual abuse and we begin here on the
west yorkshire moors
where sarah was taken and attacked by
her abusers
after speaking to the police they raped
me first and then they said to me
stop speaking to the police don't speak
to the police why are you doing that
and all that kind of stuff and then he
hit me
he cut my stomach and then he hit me
around the head it cut your stomach what
with
black blade from an old pair of scissors
sarah believes the attack was a warning
because word got out that she'd reported
historical
and ongoing sexual abuse to the police
she wants us to tell her story because
she feels officers fail to protect her
she has nowhere left to turn and many
women and children are at risk
to protect her identity we're using a
false name and an actor is voicing
sarah's words
after the attack here she fled across
the moors
so you ran down to the lake and then
what you went all the way across there
how far do you actually react
i went nearly back into town
sarah says this is a regular spot where
gangs take teenagers for sex
never ever seen a police car up here
ever ever
i've told them other people have told
them i'm sure plenty of other people
have told them
experts in child welfare have told us
despite
high profile attention on the problem
grooming gangs are still
very much at large across the uk
one former detective who blew the
whistle on manchester police is failing
to deal with the problem
later set up a foundation to help
victims but maggie oliver says
the police have not learned lessons in
the past year alone
we've helped more than two thousand
victims these are all desperate victims
who have been abused
and are being fobbed off by the
authorities how many of them are saying
the police aren't helping me
how many of those two thousand will say
i'm not getting any help just think
about it why would they come to us if
they were being helped
very good evening to you six people have
been found guilty of a range of offences
involving the sexual exploitation of
teenage girls in rotherham
these men sexually abused vulnerable
young girls in the oxford
area hundreds of girls are thought to
have been abused in telford
over two decades huddersfield has joined
an infamous
list of english towns and cities where
young
vulnerable white girls have been groomed
by
groups of men often of muslim and
british pakistani heritage
while child grooming isn't confined to
any racial group there is concern that
sensitivities over race prevented action
being taken
a report in rotherham in 2014 found
authorities
often viewed the victims of sexual abuse
as making a lifestyle choice
if all of the authorities involved had
been less concerned with their own
agendas and prejudices
and kept their focus on the children's
welfare
some of these children might not have
suffered the abuse and brutality
it was hoped lessons would be learned
but have they
sarah's abuse was by white and asian men
and began when an 18 year old she
trusted
exploited her introducing her to a group
of older men
they were just drinking and chatting and
stuff like that
and then it quickly changed to get on
the pool table
and they just started doing things
sexual things
did they all have sex with you yeah
and how old were you i was just going 14
yeah and how old were the men
they were from 18 19 to
40s 50s of the five
people who first raped you
in that garage have any of them
being prosecuted no
anyone who's ever sexually abused you've
been prosecuted
no so they're all still out there yeah
sarah had confided in a teacher that she
was in a relationship with older men but
after she got angry about it
she was questioned by police for
harassing the teacher
the attitudes towards these kids are
that they don't matter
they are an underclass they're not the
chief constables children
they're not you know the prime
minister's children these are children
often from very difficult backgrounds
who don't have a voice
they are easy to dismiss they are easy
to blame
but now that sarah is an adult she's
still struggling to be taken seriously
since reporting the historical abuse
police contacted social services
and her own children were placed on the
child protection register
over fears she was a danger to them
david greenwood specializes in legal
cases involving victims of grooming
gangs
i've had a number of cases where girls
have been targeted by social services
just by dint of having been in cse in
the past
um being considered as being unfit to
look after their their children
so potentially having their children
taken away of them from them
yeah because they were a victim of
sexual abuse yeah that's right
yeah that's scandalous isn't it yeah
that's that's what tends to happen but
it seems to be
tends to happen yeah it seems to be easy
pickings for social services
the british association of social
workers say their members aim is to work
with families to keep them together but
where it's deemed necessary to safeguard
a child it's ultimately up to the courts
for maggie oliver the issue here is that
focus again is on questioning the victim
not the predatory gangs and that's why
they continue to thrive
the excuse that is always given by the
authorities
is that things have changed that these
are historical cases if that was history
i wouldn't be in the place i'm in today
because nobody would be coming to the
foundation that is entirely the opposite
the situation is perhaps even worse we
are
inundated with current victims who have
nowhere else to turn
jane not her real name escaped an
abusive relationship two years ago but
began to worry her 14 year old daughter
who we'll call sally
was being groomed by her ex and that he
was part of a grooming gang
he'd sent her pictures of his privates
asked for pictures from her in return
um he'd been meeting her behind my back
giving her lifts giving her money giving
her six
smoking weed with her
um buying her alcohol promising to buy
her gifts
um offering to buy her cocaine
inviting her on late night drives she
just said that there was
other men in the car he'd do it when she
knew she wasn't at home with me
jane's daughter sally initially saw the
man as a father figure but that changed
when the contact became more sexualized
so what was he asking you specifically
thirsty was just asking for pictures of
my face
like oh show me what you look like
and then i was like well no why that's
weird
and then you'd ask me for pictures like
nude um so i just ignored him
he would text in asking to come pick me
up
and then he ended up sending a picture
of
himself down there
she was 14 at the time and after other
intrusions her mother called the police
i made three statements in in the police
station
they all got lost did they tell you that
your statements had got lost
yeah three on three different occasions
couldn't find them
taught me through solely what did the
police do
nothing
the man who tried to groom sally is part
of the same gang that allegedly
continued to abuse sarah
we've seen evidence she's repeatedly
reported ongoing sexual abuse
but she's been arrested for public order
offences or failing to provide a sample
and claims an officer even did this
slamming her hand in a cell door
it's extremely typical
to criminalize the victims to
investigate
a very organized gang of perhaps
20 men is very labor-intensive
it's far easier to dismiss the victim
as being drunk as being um
you know um guilty of public order
offenses
2015 we had the highest conviction rate
for child sexual abuse in our history
but it's gone backwards it's gone
backwards because of resourcing issues
it's gone backwards because you've lost
experience it's gone backwards because
agencies have lost
well they just got complacent
people think the moment that someone
turns 18 and that's it you know they're
an adult that
they can all of a sudden make this stop
and you know it's
that's completely untrue you are going
up against
a gang of men and that are very known
for
raping for beating women for torturing
it's a very scary thing to do
down that street there there's a unit on
there where they do stuff a lot of the
time
a mattress upstairs and things like that
on the floor
there's now there's just a mattress okay
and then there's a house here on the
right hand side they do stuffing
it's just just looks like a normal
street to me
yeah it's really not
how many how many men would you say are
involved in this
about about 50 odd
they're about 50 odd who are involved in
the actual sort of sexual abuse yeah
that i can that i know of who can name
stuff
do you think that they're all still
abusing young women
young girls today do you get you think
there's evidence
yeah they definitely are yeah
the numbers of cases are steadily
increasing
um rotherham was
a fairly big case for us
but the numbers of cases from different
parts of the country
arising also and do they show the same
hallmarks
everyone's the same everyone is the same
social services
intervene too late and too weakly
please don't investigate early enough
don't disrupt
abusers and yeah we're left with
with children who have had their lives
ruined
effectively west yorkshire police told
sky news that tackling serious sexual
offenses is a top priority with regards
to sarah's case they say all reports of
criminal offences
made by the victim have been
appropriately recorded and assessed
throughout the investigation we've
liaised with the crown prosecution
service a number of people have been
arrested and
interviewed we continue to engage with
the complainant to do all we can to help
signpost her to further support
we want victims to be reassured that we
do and will treat them with the utmost
sensitivity
and that their needs and welfare are
paramount
[Music]
but some victims feel ignored sometimes
criminalized
by a system they say is stacked against
them jason farrell sky news
[Music]
you